[Music]
there's been so much conversation
recently about societal bubbles echo
chambers media bubbles personal
algorithm bubbles my newsfeed told me
that everyone thought the same way I did
and there's a conflict there one of the
biggest reasons that those emerged was
that companies like Facebook at the end
of the day you know you're the product
they're selling they're actually selling
you as a sell on that network they're
selling you to advertisers and so they
need to put a nice polite bow around you
and they need to find look-alike
audiences that think like you and look
like you and the easiest way to do that
is algorithmically to focus on and at
the same time there was never the
dislike button there was the like button
right and so if you have a positive
based signaling system like that that is
designed to create a polite community of
like-minded people so that I can be
targeted easier by an advertiser because
my information is what's being sold then
the result of that is going to be a nice
polite bubble echo-chamber
and we're seeing that right now and and
people you know are astonished right
that that you know I didn't see the
other half of this community literally
half of them that thought differently
than me I don't see the ideas of that
and those are you know at no point in
modern history or in any human history
has one person had as much control over
what we think what we see what we do
then Mark Zuckerberg he has more power
than anyone in human history right now
and the scariest thing about it is
because I don't think he's innately a
bad person I don't know him enough to
say one way or the other but the problem
is it's not transparent we have no idea
what dials are being pulled or what
knobs are being turned you know that are
controlling the information coming to us
there are two big moments that I've had
that made me really think about this you
know the first is is that I used to
represent a bunch of celebrities that
were uncomfortable coming into platforms
like Facebook because they didn't know
if it was about them as a celebrity or
if it was about them as a high school
friend and so we worked early on with
Facebook and with other platforms to to
kind of set a set of rules right here's
how we would engage with a famous person
and a Facebook page would mean this you
know and so we helped those celebrities
create content to talk to their
audiences to build a direct connection
and suddenly there were people like Mark
Wahlberg or Charlize Theron or Hugh
Jackman or any of these people that are
you know massive accounts inside of
social they suddenly look like massive
media networks the idea that one person
could push a button and reach 20 million
fans was a big threat to a business
model based on me selling the
advertising not the celebrity selling
the advertising and that was really one
of the births of the algorithmic
suppression of content and so we started
seeing that you know on code dropped
Tuesdays in Facebook suddenly a person
that would get reached five million
people out of the 12 million that they
had as fans and people loved their
content would engage hundred thousand
likes three hundred thousand likes you
know really great content that people
loved we would just see that being
dialed down and we started seeing it at
such a mass scale and that's where a lot
of the ideas of this book came from is I
was looking at a trillion pieces of data
a month across this network that was
connected to at times over eight billion
connections in a system that was only
700 million people at the time so we had
a really good snapshot of what was
happening and as the business model grew
for Facebook it was dial it down dial it
down weekly and people started screaming
but you baten switched me you told me to
make content I bought you know I went
out there and I I put money into your
system to gain followers to gain fans
you know it was it wasn't just
celebrities who his companies like the
New York Times or companies like
yourselves or come
you know that wanted to reach an
audience and build a base and then
suddenly Facebook said well you know I
understand that this is a based on a
trusted system between you and your
consumer and that consumer subscribe to
you because they really want to hear
from you but we're the business in
between now and that's a hard business
to be in in a long term perspective
because I subscribe to someone because I
trust that source and I need that source
and so that algorithm until we have
transparency and then at the same time
you read about these studies where
Facebook arbitrarily without anyone
knowing took three hundred thousand
random people and turned up positive
content that week and turned up negative
content the next week and they just
wanted to do an experiment on people you
can't do experiments on people without
them agreeing oh what's in our
click-through Terms of Service you know
you know 27 pages deep you know we we're
going to do random experiments on you
socially those are things that are
really troubling to me and those are
things that in in my mind a rallying cry
around transparency of these algorithms
around transparency why am I getting
this information what is the reason
behind this and not you know six
different emotions that I can express a
WoW or sadness or anger like you
I'm not that stupid right
give me transparencies if if 70 percent
of Millennials are now receiving news
information from Facebook please show me
some transparency and the sources in the
trust factor what is the edge rank right
you guys perfect you know Facebook
perfected edge rank as a concept that
now puts it in people's vocabulary of
the trusted you know credit score
between myself as a as a content
provider in my audience right we don't
know anymore there is no transparency
it's really arbitrary and that scares me
that terrifies me and it's not just in
the newsfeed you know I had an
experience where I sent an image from a
medical textbook of a guy that I was in
a fight with and I called I said you
acting like you have a micropenis and I
went in Google and it went on search
I type micropenis and the first image I
got was from a medical textbook of a 47
year old person and I dragged that into
my facebook chat window and sent it and
instantly I was riding passenger in a
car the stereo went off because my
Spotify was connected my Facebook
account was blocked my of course
Instagram couldn't get into that I
couldn't get into SoundCloud because I
used my Facebook for them and I was I
was like well what so I tried to log
back into Facebook I said you're under
investigation for international child
pornography I was like what like I went
back to Google I was like okay well oh
that's a medical textbook it's 47 year
old I have the proof that this is not a
child pornography and then I was enraged
and I was like well who do I call so I
went in the helpline it said there's
nothing you can do you're under review
we'll get back to you within three days
maybe that was the response that's like
what these people have my identity all
these things that I'm relying upon are
connected to this system the guy never
received the image on the other side
because I called them and I said did you
get a image for me too no just shut off
that's terrifying to me someone can just
be erased from a system without any
recourse without anything that that's
that's too much power for one person and
so you know I've been pushing a lot in
what I've been saying lately is somebody
should invent identity within the
blockchain so that you know we have an
identity system that is mine right in
Iceland we have this thing called a
Kinney teller it's a unique identifier
that is literally your unique ID your
genetic records your health records your
financial records all in one right and
it's and it allows me to have total
transparency across the system and
anyone that I'm encountering so you
don't need a payday lender or a check
cashing place or a credit score or any
of these third-party parasites that
exist in our system because you have
real identity and so those are kind of
fundamental things that I think out of
this new awareness we're going to start
realizing that we need incorruptible
identity we need to have our digital
identity as part of us of who we are
as human beings as part of this system
because if we relying upon a commercial
interest like Facebook to have our
identity to capture everything it means
in our digital life and they can just
flip a switch and ask anybody that's
been blocked by Facebook
there is no recourse right you're just
you're up to somebody on a in a farm you
know deciding whether or not you're a
good person or a bad person or whether
or not you deserve an account that is
way too much power for any institution
to have over us
[Music]